that's not the plan
I was gonna ask you we talked uh the
last time me and you talked and rock was
here I think we we I think we I think
we just talked about the pregnancy
I feel like you're not the kind of guy
who's really built for marriage
I'm built for money
like I said the people I deal with I'm
gonna get money with them well at least
my [__] right my [__] like I want to
get money with her because I'm planning
for the future like I'm a house arrest I
go to jail
I want to be able to call you from jail
hey
this down the third yes to that no to
that and I don't want you to do your
business
exactly and if I notice you're a type of
person then like if I'm not there you
yeah yeah we can do this yeah yeah we
can do that we can do that
that's good it's gonna rub me the wrong
way because like why are you saying yes
to this and we haven't
are you at all we haven't said you're
worried about because I don't wanna I
get into the details of anything that
happened but I mean with anything that
is legal it could go either way right so
you kind of have to prepare for the
worst oh Lord I'm 100 worried and that's
why I'm you know I don't usually worry
about it I'm giving her the torch I'm
putting the ball in her court so that
way
don't have to worry you feel me she
seems very like you said she's
responsible she seems very good ah she's
sure gonna call me first like yo y'all
think I'm cool like hey blue they want
to do this what do you think I should do
before she say Yes No Maybe So she gonna
if that ends up happening are you
letting her take control yeah 100 yeah
somebody I mean I'm gonna be in control
my mom I mean I don't know that was new
news to me I mean he's gonna trust
anybody I mean I would know I would hope
but I didn't know that it seemed
reasonable I mean I never asked that you
know that I mean yeah no I would just
hope I would just think
what's uh is your sister still I I don't
know what's going on with your sister is
she with your mom was like because I
know yeah I mean they all got that thing
going on man I can't you know if
anything I don't got control over I
don't
I'm not gonna
call try to I know all right do that
right cause I could do this with anybody
bro
what she's like what do you mean not do
this that's weird but I'm saying I can
make anybody popular
hey that's true stand next yeah go ahead
and make them popular all you got to do
is stand next to me you're going to be
you're gonna be lit right you're right
but I'm gonna no because I'm gonna goofy
as [__] no they're still gonna be look
like if he grabs some chick from
Chipotle tomorrow and put his hand
around her and did it like this is my
new chick she's all that chick's gonna I
hope you do grab a [__] she's gonna
have 30 000 followers please [__] I
would never do that but I'm saying what
I'm saying yeah you could do that but
I'ma always pick right who's gonna pick
me feel me